en dix ans notre industrie and it et
j'ai commencé à une époque où de
multiples sociétés de production de
petite ou moyenne importance fabriquer
le contenu hexagonal aujourd'hui elles
ont toutes disparu ou ont été absorbés
par les deux entités que sont dorcel et
jacky michel les tournages en france se
font rares la plupart des productions se
font avec l'aide de canal+ diffuseur
historique les actrices ne font qu
carrière puisqu'il n'ya plus
pratiquement d'écosystèmes économique
alors qu'en est il des récentes mises en
examen oui ces réalisateurs les basques
a loupé ma tâche dit oliver suite je les
ai croisés dans ma carrière
et oui j'ai été victime de l'un d'entre
eux
attention ne se sont pas des pratiques
sexuelles filmer ce jour là dans
nous sommes attaqués attention ce ne
sont pas des pratiques sexuelles filmer
ce jour là qui me pose problème j'ai
fait bien plus hard à des performances
bien plus audacieuses ailleurs la scène
qu'ils ont tourné avec moi m'a laissé
l'amer saveurs d'avoir été un soir de
2012 la victime d'un abus de faiblesse
et d'un non respect évident mon
consentement j'ai été la victime d'une
façon de faire d'une méthode de
fabrication qui n'a rien à voir avec le
métier qui est le mien mais qui fait
tâche avec l'industrie que je défends
pire encore ces gens sont les rejetons
d'un système d'une méthode de production
qui n'a que faire des actrices ou plutôt
des amatrices qui rêve d'une carrière
glamour à la clara morgane
ses filles comme je l'étais sont les
victimes d'un rabatteur de manipulateur
de prédateurs porté par un diffuseur qui
doit sa réussite économique à la seule
exploitation de la candeur et des corps
des victimes alors comment ce groupe at
il pu enfanter laissé carte blanche à
ses petites mains qui lie forrest
quotidiennement contenu dont il a besoin
tout simplement parce qu'il n'existe
aucun véritable statut aucune légitimité
aucune existence légale pour les acteurs
et des actrices qui oeuvrent dans la
pornographie en france si elles sont
actrices pourquoi n'y at il pas de
syndicat interprofessionnel pour
défendre leurs intérêts si elles sont
actrices pour n'existe-t-il pas d'âge
ans pour protéger les débutantes des
mauvais des mauvaises personnes si elles
sont actrices
pourquoi n'existe-t-il pas
d'associations d'artistes et de
techniciens autre que les associations
féministes pour les soutenir
lorsqu'elles ont été abusés si ce n'est
pour servir d'exemple aux activistes
anti porno qui les feront culpabiliser
d'avoir fauté en acceptant de tourner
une scène tout simplement parce que les
actrices ne sont définis jusqu'à présent
que par le travail du sexe et que sous
retenir leurs intérêts flirt aux yeux de
l'état avec les notions la notion du
proxénétisme
pourquoi comme ce fut mon cas et j'ai dû
pousser la porte de cinq commissariats
pour que ma plainte soit prise en compte
car vous comprenez mademoiselle de luchi
ce que vous décrivez sont les risques du
métier vous avez signé pour cela mon
métier n'existe pas les acteurs et
actrices n'existe pas pourtant les
consommateurs consommatrices elle existe
bel et bien ils constituent même
l'essentiel du trafic internet mondial
alors voilà mesdames dessinatrice je
vous remercie de nous accueillir au sein
de cette institution oui notre
profession a besoin d'être reconnus pour
se structurer besoin d'être encadré
[Musique]